Americans saw something new this month
when it took 15 rounds of voting to let
Kevin McCarthy Speaker of the House
but our view of the political drama was
also new cameras operated by C-SPAN were
allowed far wider access than usual now
some want to make that The New Normal
Congressional correspondent Scott
McFarland has the story
one late Friday night in America the
floor of the U.S House of
Representatives saw more action and
drama than Netflix plot twists arm
twists and a different type of political
restraint the 15-round battle over who'd
be speaker of the U.S house unfolded
during one of the rare moments in which
extra cameras are allowed inside the U.S
House chamber that's putting Americans
in the room that's showing them just
what happened not doing so would be
hiding what happened every two years the
cable public affairs service C-SPAN
receives permission to record house
proceedings on the opening day of
Congress before a speaker is voted in
this time that Windows spanned not just
a few hours but four dramatic photogenic
days that was remarkable watching that
exchange on the floor you never would
have seen that from the standard
government operated fee
with the speaker finally chosen the
house is reverted back to its
government-operated feed allowing only a
few fixed distant cameras controlled by
government staff here's what this
dramatic moment would have looked like
had it occurred without c-span's cameras
inside you think these cameras should
permanently be in the house chamber
absolutely Wisconsin Congressman Mark
pocan and some colleagues from both
parties are urging leaders to
permanently give America the better view
some of us uh midwesterners kind of
shunned the cameras quite honestly we
don't like gravitate towards them we
drink water and eat Air instead for
survival but it's important for people
to see what is happening C-SPAN says
it's made that request before for more
than 40 years and been rebuffed every
time what's the resistance why didn't
this happen years ago
you would have to ask every speaker
going back to Tip O'Neill sometimes they
don't answer at all correct his
spokesman tell CBS News house Speaker
Kevin McCarthy is seeking to make the
house chamber more transparent some of
his colleagues in C-SPAN now hope all
that theater worthy of an Oscar will
convince him to allow more lights more
cameras and a better view of the action
for CBS Saturday morning Scott McFarland
the capital